[Música]
brasil superó los 400.000 muertos por
kobe 19 tras reportar más de 3 mil
decesos durante las últimas 24 horas
esto mientras el gobierno defiende su
decisión de suspender la importación de
la vacuna sputnik de fabricación rusa
el instituto gamma leia de rusia anunció
acciones legales contra el reguladores
brasileños tenemos reporte
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunció una nueva etapa en la
reactivación económica del país que
incluye la reapertura de terrazas y
cines a partir del próximo 19 de mayo el
turismo internacional abriría el 9 de
junio sin embargo este jueves anunció
que fue detectado el primer caso de la
variante india del virus en el país
el detenido líder opositor ruso alexéi
navalni apareció ante la corte por
videoconferencia por primera vez después
de poner fin a su huelga de hambre de 24
días la red de oficinas regionales del
líder opositor anunció su disolución
ante la posibilidad de que la
organización sea declarada como
extremista por parte de los tribunales
[Música]
bienvenidos sobre nueva tarde de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en tras 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en brasil
porque la nación suramericana superó los
400.000 muertos por ccoo y 19 tras
reportar tres mil decesos durante la
última jornada el país acumuló un total
de 401 mil 186 fallecidos más de 14
millones 590 mil positivos y atraviesa
su peor momento desde el inicio de la
pandemia entretanto el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro defendió su postura de
suspender la importación de la vacuna de
fabricación rusa sputnik ve argumentando
que el adenovirus que la compone tiene
la capacidad de reproducirse el
instituto ruso gamma leia que produce
las public anunció acciones legales
contra el regulador brasileño and visa y
que acusa al que acusa de difamación
desde río de janeiro nuestra
corresponsal va y es acorde con los
detalles valeria bienvenida y cuéntenos
otro hito oscuro para brasil describió
la situación sanitaria que se vive en
este momento en el gigante suramericano
bueno abril ya sabemos que ha sido el
mes más letal desde el inicio de la
pandemia con una media de 2.000 muertos
por vías y con picos diarios incluso de
más de 4000 además hay un dato también
muy duro en los primeros cuatro meses
del año han muerto más personas que en
todo 2020 por causa del coronavirus
brasil también ha cuadriplicado el ritmo
de los fallecimientos
el año pasado necesitamos 149 días para
registrar los primeros 100.000 muertos
los últimos de mil muertos se han
registrado en tan solo 36 días por todas
estas razones los expertos advierten que
no es el momento de retomar la
normalidad recordamos que brasil sigue
sin una política nacional de cuarentena
y que el presidente de jair bolsonaro se
opone a cualquier forma de restricción
de la movilidad de los ciudadanos
concretamente en río de janeiro donde me
encuentro ahora se van a reabrir otras
actividades a partir de mañana a las
playas ya funcionan de lunes a viernes y
esto preocupa a los expertos
bueno varía pero también cuéntenos por
qué decidió brasil suspender la
importación de la vacuna rusa
necesariamente justo tener ahorita más
vacunas en estos momentos para poder
hacer frente a esta tercera ola de
contagios
en términos de salud cuál es la
condición y por qué se suspende la
importación entonces del sputnik
de hecho los gobernadores de 14 estados
federales esperaban podría importar 30
millones de dosis de la sputnik b sin
embargo brasil tiene una agencia de
nacional de vigilancia sanitaria que
considerada una de las más exigentes del
mundo y el pasado lunes esta agencia la
anvisa dijo que los productores de la
vacuna rusa no presentaron la
documentación suficientemente clara que
no hay transparencia y que exactamente
este vector el adenovirus que lleva el
coronavirus dentro del cuerpo para
producir la respuesta inmune se está
replicando sin nada control pues es
validez a con nuestra corresponsal en
río de janeiro con la información y
continuamos hablando del comité 19 en
india la nueva ola de colon
no da tregua el país volvió a batir los
récords mundiales de contagios al
reportar más de 379 mil en las últimas
24 horas y tres mil 645 fallecidos para
un total de 204 mil 800 muertos en el
país el secretario de relaciones
exteriores de india aseguró que 40
países han prometido ayudar con el envío
de oxígeno y otros insumos a la nación
donde la existencia es insuficiente en
medio del colapso hospitalario el
gobierno de eeuu anunció el envío de
insumos hacia india por un monto de 100
millones de dólares para combatir la
crisis actual ocasionada por el virus
vamos ahora a francia donde se conoció
el plan en cuatro etapas del presidente
manuel macro para la reapertura del país
terrazas cafés y salas de cine reabrirán
el próximo 19 de mayo mientras el
turismo internacional empezaría a
reactivarse el 9 de junio bajo una serie
de condiciones las medidas se conocen el
mismo día en que fue detectado el primer
caso de la variante india conocida como
de doble mutación en el país desde parís
nuestra periodista erika olavarría nos
contó previamente los detalles
los franceses comienzan a ver la luz al
final del túnel de este tercer
confinamiento después de haber escuchado
esta noche los anuncios que el
presidente emmanuel macrón hizo a la
prensa regional para detallar su plan
progresivo de confinamiento de este país
en cuatro etapas la primera de ellas
comienza el próximo lunes cuando se
vuelven a autorizar los viajes entre
regiones la segunda etapa está fijada
para el 19 de mayo ese día se retrasa en
dos horas el inicio del toque de queda
de las siete a las nueve de la noche
pero lo que es más importante abre
nuevamente bares y restaurantes en
terraza y también los sitios culturales
incluso los cines los sitios que acogen
actividades deportivas y los comercios
siempre con un aforo limitado la tercera
etapa está fijada para el 9 de junio a
partir de ese día abren bares y
restaurantes en sala se atrasa
nuevamente en dos horas el toque de
queda a las once de la noche y lo que es
más importante se pone en práctica el
pase sanitario se ha certificado donde
se sabe si tenemos o no las vacunas
contra el cob y ya hemos tenido la
enfermedad después de más de 15 días o
si tenemos un psr negativo será
importante pues con ese certificado se
podrá asistir a partir de
a fecha a eventos de más de 5000
personas y finalmente la última etapa es
el 30 de junio a partir de ese día ya no
habrá más toques de queda pero ojo el
presidente no dijo nada sobre las
discotecas que siguen cerradas dice que
sigue privilegiando el trabajo a
distancia y también siguen siendo
obligatorios los gestos barrera pero
este calendario depende de un dato la
cifra de incidencia del cob y 19 esto es
el número de casos por cada 100.000
habitantes si los datos no son buenos
este calendario no se mantiene
cambiamos de información porque crítico
del kremlin alexéi navalni hizo su
primera aparición en un tribunal el tras
su huelga de hambre de 24 días se le vio
demacrado pero con ánimo suficiente para
lanzar nuevos ataques contra el
presidente vladimir putin a quien tildó
de rey desnudo y ladrona
demacrado pero aparentemente de buen
humor el crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni compareció ante el tribunal el
jueves por videollamada su primera
aparición desde que puso fin a su huelga
de hambre de 24 días la audiencia de
apelación fue contra el veredicto que le
imputa cargos de difamación de un
veterano de la segunda guerra mundial
algo que nava ni sigue rechazando
[Música]
todo este caso es una falsificación
incluso las firmas fueron falsificadas
usted señoría lo sabe muy bien y por eso
no concedió la petición de verificar las
firmas probablemente es una nueva norma
de la justicia rusa
los abogados del opositor encarcelado
afirman que el tiempo en prisión ha
tenido graves efectos sobre su salud
pero aseguran que la situación podría
haber sido aún peor si no hubiese apoyo
público si no hubiesen numerosas quejas
no habría recibido ninguna asistencia
médica como no la recibió durante mucho
tiempo la comparecencia de nabarniz se
da mientras las autoridades intentan
diezmar a la oposición con nuevos
métodos el equipo de naval de iu decidió
cerrar las oficinas de campañas
regionales después de que los fiscales
presentarán una solicitud para calificar
a la organización política de naval ni
como extremista por lo cual uno el rey
ha muerto larga vida al rey todo nuestro
tedioso trabajo en los últimos cuatro
años y vuestro apoyo no han sido en vano
hemos plantado las semillas de la
libertad en rusia que florecerán para
dar este alexéi navalni sigue cumpliendo
una condena de dos años y medio por
violar la libertad condicional de una
condena anterior por malversación de
fondos
en chile- organizaciones sociales
pidieron a la corte penal internacional
que inició un juicio contra el
presidente sebastián piñera por crímenes
de lesa humanidad presuntamente
cometidos durante las manifestaciones
antigobierno de 2019
los denunciantes sostienen que los
hechos en cuestión fueron ejecutados en
el contexto de un ataque generalizado y
sistemático contra la población civil o
con conocimiento de dicho ataque
viera niega estas acusaciones
así finalizamos en france 24 por este
millón porque ustedes pueden continuar
con más siempre al 24 punto com nos
vemos más adelante con más informaciones
quédense con nosotros
[Música]
así que